hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and i've been
investing in property for over 10 years
and in my youtube videos i like to teach
and give tips around property investment
so that you can become a successful
property investor
and as it's sunday what i'm going to be
doing is taking your questions and
answering them
and you're in luck because if you
comment below on this video
i'm going to be answering your questions
next week i do my best to read every
single comment
and start commenting your questions
below if i'm speaking
and a question leads to another question
just comment it below the more comments
the better
and i'll be choosing many comments next
week to do videos on
however this week let's see what we got
we have got
zach what's up zack how are you doing he
says hi samuel when using the brr
strategy that's the buy refurbished
refinance strategy
and remortgaging surely you would have
to pay
the 25 deposit which you can't pull
out however you say you can pull your
money
out can you please give a full example
of the brr strategy
to help my confusion thanks you've
taught me more about property than
anything
else that's great i wouldn't imagine to
have taught you more about something
else because property is kind of all i
teach
but i don't know if that's what you
meant but anyway to answer your question
yeah listen zach
brr strategy how it works is you buy a
house you buy a house
and then you force the value up on the
house and then when you refinance it
you refinance it you get normally 75
loan to value
on the new figure so in a case thing
would be
you buy a house for 50 000 pounds the
reason it's so cheap is because there's
no kitchen
it's unmortgageable so you buy it cash
or with bridging finance loans whatever
you then spend 15 000 pounds making it
mortgageable getting a new kitchen and
carpets
you've now spent 65 000 pounds it
doesn't have to be your money but you've
spent 65 grand
but the new value is 85 000 pounds
then you refinance and you get a 75
loan to value which is going to be at
least 65 000 pounds which you pay
back the loans and you're left with a
house which
you haven't actually put any money into
so that's how the strategy works hope
that helps
you are awesome what else do we have
leanne dobson does be another brr
question does brr still work if you
don't get bridge inc and buy
initially with a residential mortgage i
know the deposit amount changes so it
could affect the amount you pull back
out but can it still work
you don't want to buy a property with a
mortgage with a view to then
refurbing it and then remortgaging it
again because you'll get charged early
with penalty
fees you'll also um it's just the right
it's just the wrong
use and you won't even be able to get a
buy to let mortgage on a property that's
unmortgageable in the first place so you
want to buy
cash or with loans or with bridging
finance
and then get a buy to let mortgage on it
later once the work has been done hope
that helps
what else do we have sam hawkins my
question is how would you go about
finding a solicitor that would agree to
draw up the legal work for a lease
option agreement
that's super ironic sam hawkins because
the solicitor that i use to draw up
lease option agreements is also called
sam hawkins
so that's crazy maybe this is you just
actually scouting for business sam
no um google sam hawkins and co and they
specialize in these option agreements
really good solicitors hope that helps
sam great job
what do we have luke mills says
i'm about to sell my house and we'll
have about a hundred thousand pounds
spare to invest in property
at the moment i've been buying my
personal house while living in it
carrying out all the renovation myself
and selling it for a profit
good strategy if you can cope with the
hassle also very tax efficient strategy
as well
i'm going to continue doing this as well
as starting to buy properties to rent
good job i'm looking at brr which will
be the best buying at auction or through
the traditional way
luke buying auctions really good as long
as you
before you bid on a property you get a
survey
you get the legal pack you look at the
property and when you go to bid
set the maximum bid do not get
emotionally wrapped up in the bidding
process because when emotions are high
intelligence is low
but doing auction property can be really
really good also buying from auction but
pre-auction or post auction is good
so sounds like you're a pretty
experienced landlord investor property
owner so yeah go for auction but just
make sure you know what you're doing
and be careful but good luck keep
reposting how you get on
anthony says as a first-time property
investor is it better to start buying as
a limited company or an individual buyer
anthony it really depends so buying for
a company
is more tax efficient because they
brought in section 24 which they've been
phasing in the last few years and
section 24
says that if you buy as an individual
you cannot claim your
mortgage payments as tax deductible
which is a bit of a problem
if you own properties as an individual
however there are advantages to buying
as an individual as well
normally your interest rates will be a
little bit cheaper um
it will be if you're only ever gonna buy
one house and it's a small house and the
mortgage payments aren't gonna be big
anyway
it might make sense to just buy it as an
individual if you're planning on growing
a portfolio scaling it
does make sense buying through a company
so i would recommend you speak to an
accountant and work out what's best for
you
next lewis clark good lewis clock if i
remember you are
16 from scotland and work really hard
having a paper and stuff
that might be a different lewis clark
but if it's you you're awesome and you
comment a lot so let's say do you think
buy to let will be the same in let's say
three to five years time
or will it start to be oversaturated
thanks louis
it won't be the same no but it won't be
over saturate
with property investing things always
change slightly over time
you've got to be fluid and you've got to
adapt but ultimately people will always
need somewhere to live
so as long as you know what people want
pay attention to the demand and then
offer the correct supply
there's always going to be good business
in property unless something absolutely
crazy happens like we turn into a
communist country or something but
despite all what's going on i can't
really see that happening hope that
helps keep up the good work
next michelle says no mitchell says best
way to start in property with under 5k
if you've got under 5k you're going to
struggle to
buy a property you could potentially
start deal packaging or potentially
i would say if you've only got 5k and
you want to get into property
at least use at least use 1 000 pounds
of that to invest in yourself because
5 000 is not going to get you very far
unless you've got a good brain and you
have good training in my honest opinion
next nathan says what strategy is best
to get into property at a young age
if you're a young age it doesn't really
make any difference if you're old young
i mean i guess i guess probably if
you're young
you've got more i don't want to offend
any old people now but you've got more
willingness to get your hands really
dirty so
make the most of being young maybe be an
apprentice get your hands dirty work for
free you've not got the overheads that
someone might have that's got lots of
kids and mortgages
um two holidays a year that they have
scheduled with their wife
so just really make the most of learning
and soaking up information and being a
sponge
would be my opinion and be patient but
also work really hard hope that helps
haida says hey samuel do you still think
that prices will drop
due to covet 19 yes prices are gonna
drop and although some people might be
thinking haha samuel you were wrong
because house prices haven't really
dropped much yet
i don't think they're gonna drop crazy
crazy okay and it also of course depends
on the area
but there's usually a little bit of a
stall before house prices drop so
520 000 properties
were paused from from being sold that's
gonna have a rippling effect sometimes
sellers are just a little bit too
stubborn to realize and it could take a
few months but yes i do
think house prices are going to drop not
in every area but in the
majority of the country properties
prices are going to drop
by about 10 15 over the next 12 months
in
my opinion hope that helps lewis parker
has samuel 365 replaced the in-person
free crash courses
or are these intended to be up and
running again soon lewis they have
replaced them yes
right now we're not running crash
courses physically so samuel 365
you do get the property investors crash
course for free on that platform as a
member you also get mentoring coaching
and advanced training
however i do plan on running the crash
courses again
down the line once all this craziness is
over and it's safe to do so i do plan on
running them again
in the future muhammad ali
hey man i'm a college student i don't
want to leave college
is it hard to do both at the same time
yeah everything's hard
okay i mean if you're a college student
i don't know how much time you spend
doing college stuff but we've all got
the same amount of hours in the day
we've all got responsibilities
the the the the president or prime
minister has the exact same amount of
time
as the unemployed person that fills
their day walking their dog and watching
eastenders
it's about how you manage your time so
my my recommendation to muhammad
would be yeah just set your priorities
make sure that you're spending
the most of your time and prioritizing
what's most important at that time which
might be college
um but yeah do as much as you can work
hard absolutely most entrepreneurs that
become multi-millionaires
you know work worked a lot of hours to
get to where they're at so don't be
afraid of hard work
next is magisha says i'm 15 and i ain't
got no money
i'm struggling to work out the question
there but i'll give you some advice
anyway
my advice if you're 15 and you ain't got
no money is to instead of focusing on
what you don't have focus on what you do
have
rather than rather than coming to life
or to me or to the property game
thinking i haven't got you know i'm just
15 and i haven't got
think about what you have got i said i
haven't got any money why don't you say
i'm hungry i watch samuel leads his
videos and i am subscribed to his
channel if you're not subscribed you've
got to subscribe you'll just suddenly
start having magical things happen when
you subscribe
don't believe me check it out um but
focus on what you've got i've got
passion i'm hungry i've got knowledge
i've watched samuel's videos i've got an
uncle that says that
he's a builder who can come out and like
just think about what you have got
and then flip the cards and become
successful but i relate to you buddy i
left school at 16 with paper and money
and i'm from the same kind of background
so i get it but just focus on what you
have got not what you haven't got hope
that helps
good luck though my friend ricky m i
would love to see you
and graham stefan graham stefan but
unfortunately the usa has banned flights
to europe but in future that would be an
amazing video
i don't think if flights were going
graeme stefan would necessarily just
jump on one to europe to come and do a
youtube collab with me
however thanks for the compliment listen
graeme stefan i
i'm not i'm massively familiar with what
he does but i have seen his youtube
videos
he seems like a really cool guy he's
young he's successful and he's got more
subscribers than i do so um i'd very
happily
collab with him go on to his channel and
just say do a collab with samuel leeds
i'm sure if everybody does that he
probably would do a collab
maybe not fly to europe but yeah very
happy to do that he seems like a cool
guy
all right last question this is
makma who says what is the process step
by step
to buying a house by to let
that's quite a that's quite a long
answer to that question the process step
by step of buying a buy to let property
all right firstly you've got to identify
siri doesn't understand but i do it's
okay firstly is you've got to identify
the area you want to buy in
secondly you've got to speak to estate
agents you've got to find an area which
where you can buy low rent high have a
high return on investment
pick up the phone book some viewings
don't be afraid to book viewings
booking a viewing on a house does not
mean that you have to buy the house
it's the same as when you go to the
shops you might have a little walk
around have a look
there's nothing wrong with looking at
booking viewings going to auctions
just to get a feel and to see what's
around so
and then once you put an offer forward
the offer is accepted you then get a
memorandum of sale you then send that to
a solicitor they draw the contracts up
you get a survey to the property
you then get an exchange in a completion
date you find the letting agent to put a
tenant in
so there's a lot to it so i wouldn't
really be able to answer that in one
question however
if you stick around to the channel i'm
going to be doing loads and loads more
videos
please don't forget to comment your
questions on this video below i'm going
to be doing my very best to answer
and guys thank you so much for your
support thank you so much for engaging
with me
although i'm a property investor when i
buy houses and rent them out that on its
own
doesn't really do it for me i love doing
that i make a lot of money doing that i
vlog that but i just love communicating
with people and seeing other people do
well bouncing ideas off answering your
questions so i appreciate your support
thank you for being a subscriber if
you're not a subscriber i'll say it for
the third time do it now now is your
chance
well not that you can't do it tomorrow
but just do it now and i'll see you next
time thanks so much peace out god bless